die nasa hat tatsächlich eine heiße spur
für leben auf enceladus gefunden so
wurde tatsächlich molekularer
wasserstoff im vorbeiflug von cassini an
enceladus in den garten von denen
entdeckt genau danach hatten die
wissenschaftler gesucht es ist ein
klares zeichen von hydrothermalen
quellen orten also an denen es auch sehr
spezielle lebensformen hier auf der erde
gibt was wir jetzt wissen und wo noch
leben in unserem sonnensystem entstanden
sein könnte jetzt den krieg zum science
fiction herzlich willkommen
echt manchmal habe ich das gefühl wir
sind so dicht davor morgen passiert
wissen quasi aus dem nichts gibt es
plötzlich die bestätigung und jetzt sind
wir der entdeckung von außerirdischen
leben wieder so nahe gekommen denn was
die nasa jetzt herausgefunden hat auf
enceladus gibt es die idealen
bedingungen für leben zum einen wurde
der molekularen wasserstoff tatsächlich
gefunden
beim letzten vorbeiflug an enceladus
ende 2015 sollte er ja gefunden werden
das war die aufgabe dieses fleischs und
er wurde gefunden
er deutet auf hydrothermale quellen hin
denn durch hitze wird molekularer
wasserstoff aus wasser abgespalten hier
auf der erde sind solche hydrothermalen
quellen ein ganz besonderer ort für
leben
am anfang der nahrungskette stehen hier
nämlich nicht pflanzen sondern mikroben
und sie gewinnen ihre energie dort nicht
aus photosynthese wie pflanzen sondern
aus im wasser gelösten
schwefelverbindung ob es diese auf
enceladus gibt ist unklar allerdings
haben die wissenschaftler der nasa eine
andere energiequelle gebunden
das wasser dort enthält nämlich 14
prozent wasserstoff 0,8 prozent
kohlendioxid co2
das sind die zutaten für die metabo
genese hier auf der erde produzieren
mikroben in den dunklen tiefen der
ozeane aus wasserstoff und co2 methan
und gewinnen dabei energie das ist
dieses jahr natur verfahren bau und
jetzt geht es direkt weiter wobei direkt
bei der nasa schon ein paar jahre
bedeuten hubble hat nämlich etwas
ähnliches wie auf enceladus auf dem
jupitermond europa gefunden sei sie von
themen zumindest spricht alles dafür
haben antwort nämlich 2014 und 2016
fontänen fotografiert die sonde galileo
hat genau an der stelle an der hubble
die fontänen gewundert bereits ende der
90er jahre eine warme stelle auf der
oberfläche von europa gefunden jetzt
sind weitere missionen zu europa
unterwegs um dort nach leben zu suchen
die europäische raumfahrtagentur esa
starren 2022 eine mission zu den
einzigen jupiter moden und eben auch für
europa sie wird 2030 dort ankommt und
neben auch die eisfontänen dort
untersuchen auch die nasa plant eine
mission zu europa sie sendet den europa
clipper auch hier sollen die ice von
themba durch
genauer analysiert werden noch wirkliche
beweise für leben werden wohl erst
landen missionen bringen können die in
den ozean unter den dicken eis richten
dort sondern u-boote absetzen können
auch an solchen missionen wird derzeit
gearbeitet allerdings muss dafür erst
ein eis und mit idealen bedingungen für
leben und einer zumindest an ein achten
ssigen stelle dünnen eisschicht gebunden
werden es kann also noch etwas dauern
und auch im stern system taps man sieht
es im moment nicht so gut aus der
zuschauer alpha duplo vielen dank hat
nämlich eine studie aufgetan der nach
der rote zwerg also der stern im zentrum
dieses systems immer wieder aufflackert
also wie unsere sonne
sonnenwinde sternen winde aufstände dies
aber zu oft und zu stark für die
wahrscheinlich zu schwachen magnetfelder
der planeten in diesem system dadurch
hätten sie schon alle ihre atmosphären
verloren echt gefühlt waren hier die
letzten tage so dicht davor leben zu
finden und jetzt ist das erst mal wieder
in die ferne gerückt naja schauen wir
mal auf jeden fall erfahrt ihr hier bei
klicks und science fiction immer das
neueste und wenn er davon nichts
verpassen wollt dann drückt man hier ein
abo aufs auge und vergesst nicht mehr
ein auf die glocke zu geben und wer
jetzt erst abonniert muss noch eine
menge nachholen hier ist die best of
play list von pixum bis dann bleib dran